le 0 5 me pour cent de plus pour
l'électricité les accidents de l'été
soyez prudents l'an dernier plus de 5000
ans sont pas revenus fédéraux mu 2e
journée du championnat de france 2 match
vedette strasbourg metz et marseille
paris saint germain et le soir j'ai
planté à prendre la route des vacances
je suis content pour vous un bref rappel
des conseils de bison futé ne partez pas
ce soir hier
ce qui voudrait aux mineurs de suivre la
création du journal colonisés et ne
voulait pas autant que possible demain
samedi entre 3 heures et 15 heures
autrement dit entre tout à l'heure trois
heures du matin et demain après chercher
toutefois que lorsque vous avez la
décence à partir de minuit vous a
réservé un sens plus cher une wii et 7
ans ce samedi 4 ou qu'entre en vigueur
les audois passion rendu inévitable par
une décision prise de 28 juin à genève
par l'opep des pays exportateurs
contrairement à venir étudier la
précédente se fourvoie si l'augmentation
du brut se répercute à part égale au
coût de choses près sur le carburant aux
taux de fioul domestique et le gazole
carburant le seul secteur où partir de
ce soir minuit le super sera donc un 3
francs 5,4 dans la région paris pour les
départements le présent différents le
calcul est facile + 10 centimes plus 10
centimes aussi pour l'essence ordinaire
qui passent donc à 895 minutes le gaz on
augmente lui de 9 centimes et passe à 2
francs tout jute
quant au fioul domestique un front 19
l'électricité augmentera à partir du 6
ou prochain selon un barème complet dans
narnia bhl suivant laissera pas les
heures d'orgue et la basse tension
c'est-à-dire le double des particuliers
4 % nouvelle hausse du crédit également
plusieurs banques ont porté aujourd'hui
leur tour de base à 10,0 5%
la bnp d'abord puis le sait le crédit du
nord gelée gaz n'étant fait le grand
données de référence à laquelle
s'ajoutent les marches habituel cela
signifie en clair que le crédit comme
les brûlures de 15 projets taureau de 20
% pour les biens de consommation comme
les voitures les machines à laver les
postes et les pda
il est plus que probable que la part des
autres grandes d'un million de
mouvements
c'est la troisième en moins d'un mois et
cette escalade du prix de l'argent en
france et provoqué essentiellement par
la hausse mondiale 2 minutes et 40 en un
temps où la pénurie de pétrole crée tant
de problèmes divers dans le monde et où
nous risquons chaque jour que l'essence
deviennent rares arrêtons nous quelques
instants sur les efforts du gouvernement
m
pour mettre sur pied des acteurs à bas
prix intéressants entre d'une part la
frange rap repart persique qui sont
comme vous le savez de très gros
producteurs d'autres avec les pays
arabes du golfe
la france met en place une politique
d'amélioration du second constat au
départ ils ont pétrole dont nous avons
besoin nous c'est à dire la france est
aussi l'europe car ici la race est un
peu le maître d'oeuvre lyrique
intéressant ces barrages ragots mais si
ces pays en énergie nous avons nous la
technologie à laquelle ils aspirent
d'où l'idée de rapporter le gréa morts
3000 et rideau devant un four paysage
quand on parle de technologie on pense
bien entendu au matériel militaire
français dans les paysages emprunte un
chemin de croix mais c'est un exemplaire
entre 2d mais un exemple important parce
que les pays du golfe aspire à ne plus
dépendre du seul matériel américain la
déstabilisation en iran les
sur le président carter entendu les
leaders alliés de la diversifier dans
ses prévisions
car pelez les gens séoudiens par exemple
n'apprécie plus comme avant la politique
américaine
par voie de conséquence l'arabie
séoudite pourrait être partie prenante
dans la politique de rapprochement arabe
aux rappeurs avec le congrès les bahreïn
les émirats où il peut être dira qu on a
beaucoup vu les dirigeants français ces
temps ci sur les rives du golfe
monsieur françois 11 exemple qu'à
renouveler l'an dernier c'est pourquoi
nous avons monsieur giscard d'estaing
pourrait y faire d'ici la fin de l'année
une visite officielle le parlement
minutes à se séparer sans nous en sommes
seconds des grandes mesures pour faire
face à la crise énergétique le président
du milk artères j'avais demandé
d'approuver au cours d iran comme les
élections des experts l'ont rédigé des
futures institutions du pays se sont
déroulées sans incident les partis laïcs
et les religieux modérés avaient appelé
nous l'avons dit au boycott des
élections car il estime comme les
généraux d'état dans un climat la
participation était néanmoins très fort
mais légèrement inférieur du référendum
de mars sur la république islamique
les partisans de l'ayatollah khomeiny
qui représentait plus de la moitié pour
candidats sont certains d'obtenir une
majorité écrasante le verra son monsieur
légumes puis le jeu sera mien quitte
l'hôpital après quinze jours de
traitement
il devra encore observer un repos d'une
huitaine de jours selon un sondage de
nos marques diotte alain menu 49 posera
souhaiterait que le gouvernement
béguines démissionne alors pour 35 %
sont pour son maintien
demain commente ait faim les
négociations et j'ai pu joindre le
réseau sur l'autonomie des palestiniens
dans les territoires occupés par israël
mais seuls dans une atmosphère de crise
la relation géniale
les quelque 100 de seconde zone cette
détérioration serait dû à certaines
positions nouvelles des etats unis sur
le problème palestinien en effet peser
gare ter semble oui je suis d'avis
quelques temps prêté une oreille plus
attentive à l'exposé des positions et
d'ailleurs
selon des informations venues de turquie
monsieur yasser arafat se rendrait
bientôt dans plusieurs capitales
occidentales
continuant ainsi sa série de voyages de
l'ouest commencé en juillet parviennent
à les laver rencontre et l'autrichien
secret l'ancien chancelier allemand
monsieur vie libre l'un des principaux
architectes du traité de paix entre
israël et l'egypte et rozenn tout nouvel
ambassadeur est arrivé aujourd'hui en
france c'est un homme brillant et un
juriste et mines en envoyant à paris
match le gouvernement israélien pour but
d'orienter le pays surtout pour ce qui
est de l'attitude du gouvernement
français face au récent traité de paix
l'adversaire
les minutes cette politique de paix pour
toi la vie disent elles c'est la seule
voie prise il est pour toi sûrement
arriver à la paix total recall ayant il
faut commencer que du mal et c'est
pourquoi nous considérons que le traité
de paix entre l'egypte et israël
c'est un premier traité de paix d'un gie
série d'été avec le genre avec les
autres pays arabes
cherchant de l'âge de tout ce qui peut
lui et qui n'eut plus froids un croc il
ya des voies différentes pour aboutir à
cette paix mais qui en fait rien venir
estimez vous êtes de ceux traités par
l'egypte
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que le
gouvernement français n'a pas débordé
d'enthousiasmé
est ce que vous espérez ni changer cette
vente autonome mesure où la position que
vous avez mentionné est elle la vérité
sinon expliquer leur point de vue et est
d'essayer de convaincre que notre voix
est juste
monsieur habib bourguiba le combattant
suprême président de la république
tunisienne a aujourd'hui 76 et dakar et
ses visiteurs en excellente forme
il voit le maire est plongée
minutieusement dans la piscine de sa
résidence à l'occasion de son
anniversaire il a gracié neuf opposants
à sa politique incarcéré jusqu'ici dans
un pénitencier près de bizerte et libéré
nous y suivrons ancien secrétaire
général de la centrale syndicale
tunisienne et condamnés pour avoir
fomenté les émeutes de janvier 78 58
minutes félon intendante à la porte de
cette prison tunisienne ligne en a qui
sont eux qui ont ce soir de bonnes
raisons d'être optimiste aux jeunes des
condamnés les menus dans les bornes
gracié ce soir neuf de ces prisonniers
politiques et on lui prête l'intention
d'en gracié d'autres et peut-être tous
les autres geste symbolique après les
luttes de janvier soit monsieur
bourguiba tend ainsi la main à ses
adversaires qu'il avait précédemment
châtiment ce qui concerne le principal
est gracié c'est à dire l monsieur habib
achour
c'est un syndicaliste très vite me 9,7
un vieux combattant il a plus de 65 ans
donc en raison de ses états de service
si je puis dire et de son âge et de sa
santé
il a été libéré mais c'est aussi un
geste luc devaux parce que c'est une
libération d'un homme politique et des
prisonniers politiques est toujours
quelque chose le populaire mais il reste
encore du plaisir à nous espérions mais
selon et quelques quelques autres et
beaucoup de tunisiens et beaucoup dans
mon lit de la tunisie une libération
plus massive
c'est la trouille à tout à fait la
france mais il faut à il faut pas se
tromper c'est pas le chili il ya en tout
ces quelques secondes de trop mais
on en a libéré dix il reste cinquantaine
je crois je suis bien certain que la
même certainement libéré dans nos cours
à ce que les autres lui ont libéré
rapidement et plus ceux qui souhaitent
cette libération la démocratisation du
régime tunisien
aj grave dépression et plus c'est la
rubrique cas pastore accident est
toujours trop fourni les noyales par
exemple
hier nos exilés tragédie de salon où les
amateurs de plaisance trop pressé était
partie naviguer sans prendre les
précautions indispensables
cette fois il s'agit de la connectique
du muet sur la plage au second
d'aquitaine des gens se baigner dans des
buy in
ce sont de longs trous d'eau creusée
dans le sable va parallèlement à lacaune
numérique
willy van durme avançons danger or à
certains moments très précis fin de la
marée descendante et début de la marée
montante
les bennes sont parcourue par des
courants violents qui peuvent entraîner
à belém part c'est ce qui s'est produit
hier les personnes ont été emportées par
les eaux croyable 17h30 hier sur la
plage du pin sec près d'hourtin
malgré la forte mer et le drapeau jaune
hisser sur le post le secours des
baigneurs sont nombreux dont nous et
puis pratiquement le mans 14 nombreuses
et emportés par le groupe dont l'âme est
descendante en divers endroits de la
plaque site une page où il ya énormément
de buy in et les gens ce qu'est ce que
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais il s'est
introduit sable qui se remplit avec avec
les marées avec les vagues déferlantes
et qui se vide par un seul côté le
procès de bayeux-lisieux jfx accords de
second violon
alors les gens ont bien sûr nous voulons
pas se plier à la réglementation des
baignades se paye automatique au chaud
ici ses impressions de télé c est se
baigner en sortie de buy-in et et en
dehors de la dda limite surveiller son
premier pas beaucoup de volontaires moi
même j'ai voulu l'amener mais je n
aurais pas bhl monsieur des lois allant
au filet et avec beaucoup d'erreurs a
porté le fil n o mns kla beaucoup
beaucoup se sont rapprochés au filet et
on en a ramené pas mal à l'inquiéter
certains nageurs juste essoufflé mais
d'autres qui avaient perdu comme
nettement leurs connaissances
le bilan de ce drame un mort et cinq
dixièmes sais qui c'était sept autres
personnes cinq allemands et deux
chiliens ont été hospitalisés mais ils
sont maintenant hors de danger la paix
alors un conseil des blessures nouvelle
quand souhaité les indications des
surveillants sont les blancs est la
forêt brûlent en corse
un centaine d'hectares ont été des cas
rendre flou par des incendies depuis 24
heures la sécheresse qui sévit en corse
du sud et plus particulièrement
md'altitude accroît l'intensité des
flammes trois appareils canadiennes sont
utilisés pour combattre ce mal dont
l'origine serait due à la pratique de
l'écobuage l'écobuage pour révéler à
fertiliser un terrain en brûlant
herbes et les racines et pour mettre
tous à graviers notre conseiller général
corse
ces pratiques ruines l'agriculteur rêve
mais vu seconde redon c'est une
charmante localité bretonne située en
ile de man fo millions en main le long
de la loire atlantique tous ceux qui se
rendent par le train ou par la route en
bretagne sud sont presque obligé de
trappes
or des lèvres les yeux pour son vente au
second à travers le portrait de redon
nous nous sommes posé la question
que font-ils pendant la période des
vacances il y a ceux qui va même regard
de parents le second lassé des gens qui
vont à la mer ou qui en reviennent un
reportage de patricia kaas
rue de bretagne lance juste un milieu
coupant sa grand place en deux les
trucks et 20 minutes anciens où les
vacanciers en dessous moins fréquenté le
canal de nantes à brest et son port de
plaisance le long du canal sur la route
de rennes volley caravane face le
personnage garnier qui occupent l'usiné
depuis mi juillet aujourd'hui dans l'
usine il n'y a plus personne
96 400 villes à 10 ans on était neuf
cents c'est une lente hémorragie ici
dans les machines agricoles depuis
qu'elle surnomme ailleurs depuis dix ans
sans coup d'éclat c'est tout le tissu
industriel trop usés ou trop léger qui
s'effiloche tandis que la pression
démographique l'exode rural et le double
de la moyenne nationale à ces femmes
hier ils étaient 400 ils sont plus que
deux ans c'était la capitale briquet
mais si c'est une usine du bâton qui
l'un de ses relais à profit social et
comment les volets fermés depuis les
monts alors là c'est la laiterie et ils
étaient 180 là deux ans ils sont plus
que 150 ça c'est une menuiserie alors
normal ils étaient devenus les est
fermée du second
il est en vacances et c'est pas les
congés si on a retenu un gîte rural à
saint-jean-de-maurienne la femme
travaille elle a le goût de l'or car les
gamins on y va doubler un mois on n'y
voit qu'un jour ça fait plusieurs années
qu'on parle d'eux de se payer un voyage
en cause alors je n'ai toujours pas
trouvé de travail alors peut-être dans
quelques années
pas de projet on dit seulement pour
l'instant une attitude générale la peur
de l'avenir
je le texte ou même des vents qu'elle va
cause que l'on touche 90% du salaire 45
au sol et social que une hlm couperet de
son potager
les vacances se passent ici quelqu'un
qui pique nique aux alentours en
campagne peut-être jusqu'à la mer à 40
km c'est tout l'intelligent tout bon ben
il faut tout de suite aux quatre anciens
ça me mène peut-être vous aider les
autres à partir au matin faut pas penser
à ces nous on voit nos petits problèmes
et puis bon bien sûr comme ça on parle
de 300 emplois à venir
un système des aides exceptionnelles ont
été mises en place avant tout mac et des
industriels pour que le temps et les
vacances ne soit plus suspendu au dessus
de redon à longwy la fermeture des deux
derniers au journal de m
des militants de la cfdt occupe nous
sommes soit révélé la population de la
ville a été invitée à venir assister à
la dernière coulée de méthane sur place
jean claude renaud avoue ne rien
regretter
look seconde à sierre usines
sidérurgiques centenaire née en 1880
c'est un défi nitivement et cet après
midi
les syndics antenne de l'harmonisation
du voisin que l'on a assisté à la
dernière coulée du dernier haut fourneau
de la chienne la restructuration
industrielle 1,16 la jolie 1600 salariés
90 euros ou 100 seront partis avant noël
700 seront mutés vers d'autres unités et
rugit barlow et notamment du pc sont
volontaires pour partir en et capitule
de 50 mille francs et 200 prendront leur
pré retraite à 50 ou 55 ans pourtant
malgré ces mesures sociales a prévu par
la convention s'il ya deux événements
lusine ne meurt pas sens de l'âge adulte
et une en nous ou les dernières tonnes
de fonte vont couler sur le sable
beaucoup d'ouvriers ne savent pas encore
ce qu'ils vont devenir
par exemple les ouvriers qui ont entre
50 et 55 ans journaux qui ont la route
plausible penser qu'ils partiraient en
préretraite mais la direction vient
d'annoncer que seuls 120 employés et
agents de maîtrise du mur non
cinquante ans avec 80% de leur salaire
les ouvriers eux devront attendre
septembre
est ce que le plan que va t on demain 4
août la chiers sera fermée et longwy en
congé la manifestation d'aujourd'hui
symbolique au dernier carré 19 ans parmi
les syndicalistes présents certains ont
déjà empoché la prime de départ de 58
francs et cherche du travail ailleurs il
ya ceux comme ne peuvent pas ma fille
revient sur ce dont on soit plus il y a
aussi les français qui travaillent
justement pour des vacances quand je dis
ceux qui travaillent pour les vacances
ou qui visent des vacances je pense aux
hôteliers aux restaurateurs valff grimpe
de materis le temps il existe des
histoires presque inconnu sans doute
parce qu'elle est très discrète est
qu'elle s'exerce dans des endroits
eux-mêmes discret cette profession s'est
scindé russie et les anciennes écoles
mal au dos l'éclusier vous allez voir
est une édition
on se promène sur les canaux sa
dépouille est survenu quand on découvre
un inconnu
par exemple sur le canal du nivernais
dans l'échelle de sa synthèse pensée
dangereux mais j'ai discuté comme ça
autant tourner une manivelle avec
l'éclusière irène charte
le bien isolé à bientôt
oui je n'ai pas le talent des gens
pensent et colis vers nîmes péniche une
peau jamais pensé aux me suis dit il
j'avais deux mois cette maman le fric ne
pouvez pas vous en permanence en
invitant à l'ancienne ont fermé les yeux
sur la scéne et sa maman d'une petite
faustine excessif comme ça les fonds
qu'il s'en fout c'est vous êtes
incollables et les chaunois amis avec
qui vous avez l'oeil qui se passe chaque
année c'est un peu dur pour un petit
centre c'est comme ça vous allez oui ces
commissions de vérité
et puis il reste du temps il n'a pas un
petit copain il a personne
la chine est un de nos précédents celui
ton café au lait est d'abord pour nous
maintenant
mais la fin chose que la vie sur notre
vidéo il va trouver que sa tournée
passer vite et qui m'agace c'est avant
tout une petite histoire de lui des
choses qui nous ont marqués santos
vous savez quand j'étais plus jeune je
me désole de la route afin que ces bons
transports doit prévoir la silicose
péniche c'était des gens qui
connaissaient fouet alors qu'après si
elle va directement
oui je crois que c'est balma de
l'éclusier on française et ce n'est pas
pour porter j'ai sambre pour des excuses
moi j'ai 140 et qu'elle l'a très peu vu
que beaucoup moins que lui c'est pas
beaucoup
la queue
ma seconde revenons à des préoccupations
de maths ça met 22 autres pays quant aux
solvants et de payer vos impôts sur le
revenu mensuel
cette forme de paiement avait débuté
remise atteint la bulle
elle est donc avant le second ancêtres
prédit-elle monsieur baroin ministre du
budget estime que le système rencontre
de plus en plus de partisans en 76 par
exemple 22% et ayem le porter il se fera
et le pack plein de cette course
place alors à jour 21 mai un nouveau
rendez vous importants sur antenne 2
dans la série de nos programmes question
de temps jean pierre elkabbach oliverio
présenteront le dernier film de la série
qu'elle france quel point ce droit mais
il m'a oublié tous bords de la gironde
un reportage inhabituel puisqu'il est le
résultat d'une collaboration nouvelles
et parfois un peu loin même de l'antenne
de violon parole aux girondins à travers
leur conseil général comme nous l'avions
fait auparavant pour les habitants de
valeur de maints endroits mais là où
vente au second la gironde
donc question de temps lundi ce lundi
qui vient à 21 h
décidément le score on m'avait un membre
de l'opposition du gouvernement français
le rétablir la nécessité d'un visa pour
les sud africains qui veulent venir chez
nous mesures prises pour empêcher la
tournée des springboks à préserver la
preuve du sud affirme que malgré cela
climatique et communes les springbocks
ne renonce pas encore à leur tournée en
france et qu'ils demanderont
officiellement les visas nécessaires ne
soit vers peyras le président de
fédération française de rugby
elles avaient déjà pris position terre
primeur de cette tenue ce bouquin ne
cache pas sa déception devant la
décision du gouvernement c'est navrant
pour le rugby rétablir
leurs visas c'est encore à démontrer
alors quelle sera votre réaction
avez-vous l'intention de céder une
ruelle de la fédération at elle arrêté
mais pas question ce n'est pas une
épreuve de force
la position de la fédération a été
arrêté depuis fort longtemps et ne
comprennent rien promis mais oui grâce à
l'impression que nous avons prise il ya
déjà plusieurs années
présidente pourquoi malgré l'opposition
de nombreuses organisations restez-vous
partisans de cette tournée des
springboks 5 4 il ya un basque 15 ans
avaient été lancées l'année contre
l'apartheid c'est parce que c'est
l'argent et nouveau pas changé d'opinion
on parce que pour faire plaisir à pierre
jaccaud pas le temps il ya 95% emoa
sportif qui est d'accord a totalement
avec nous demain qu'une nouvelle ésente
la venue des courriels de compromis ou
une ça c'était un match tu avais demandé
à ferrol battre au retour de leur match
elle alla est inquiète faire une tournée
enfin mon pays de galles l'instant je
savais très bien que conservateur comme
selon l'union et l'année ça m'étonnerait
qu'il se soit arrêtée ils n'ont pas peur
de se gausser que vraisemblablement nous
font des tournées beaucoup plus souvent
avec lanvin et van damme avait jusqu'à
présent
oui ces différentes prises de position
ne change rien la politique de
libération n'était rugby carangues la
violence comme toujours sur mes
positions
nous pensons que le sport devrait rester
dans la politique nous sommes les
premiers à regretter que la politique
prenne le pas sur le sport toi ma fille
elle même et demain à bayonne à
marsillargues plus vente spéciale avec
un même si j'ai bien compris il faut
arracher à l'animal un certain nombre
d'abus note que l'on a fixés sur lui un
reportage
fr3 manqué d'y donner pour leur aptitude
à ce genre de spectacle pénètre dans les
arènes avec vous auront une qu'aucun des
deux compos blanc que l'on appelle des
glands le tout nu par des ficelles
le but du jeu est d'arriver à l'aide
d'un crochet attrapé chacun de ses
attributs
c'est le travail
pour chaque attributs décroché il
empoche une prime une tradition
méridionale puisque on a retrouvé dans
des textes dans des actes les habitants
de ces camps qui lie à 2001 je les aurai
tous à des jeux thorel mais ce n'est
qu'à partir du xviie siècle que la
course camarguaise
à commencer par prendre un peu la forme
que vous voyez c'est à dire et table on
a commencé à ce moment-là remettre les
attribuent aux cornes des taureaux des
attributs qui l'a privé de noailles
aujourd'hui cours de manades un concours
de manades avec des taureaux provenance
dans la plupart des cas de courson royal
et la cour royale
et comme concédé six meilleurs taureaux
de l'élevage sinon qu'ils n'ont pas
démérité dans la siag où l'on a pu voir
quelques jolis coups de tête
m
c'est un sport justement dangereux mais
que tu viens de dire que c'est un sport
par s'arrêter
reconnu comme tel il y a trois ans par
le ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
justement et nous aussi
mais nous voudrions maintenir en hauteur
un corpus berthelot parce
qu'effectivement c'est un sport très
dangereux toutes les années 40 à 50
blessures dont certaines assez grand
parce qu'il ya des amis ou naturels sont
tous d'abord adoré ici et lorsqu'ils
deviennent galette vous savez qu'on ne
l'est plus jamais on les laisse mourir
de leur belle mort est très souvent on
leur fait des tombeaux que les gens vont
fleurir ou vénéré pendant des années
mars
du tout bon
se rappelle encore lille mais sommes un
peu plus en chemin il y a la deuxième
journée du bon vin solent important par
des trains cje appel indirect olivier
comment cela se présente à paris saint
germain masse léon zitrone il y à
maryvonne pour ce premier match de la
saison du paris st jean se fera au parc
des princes malgré les vacances et le
mois d'août il y a comme vous allez
pouvoir le voir 40 mio eur qui sont
venus assister au premier match de la
saison du paris saint germain
quel est votre favori eh bien écoutez
sans vouloir être trop averti je pense
que je le paris saint germain va favori
de ce match avec notamment les pigments
de ces deux nouvelles vedettes et shaone
baisse l'homme au gant noir et le
brésilien abel donc si je veux me risque
à un pronostic je dirais le paris
saint-germain et puis au moment où les
deux équipes pénètrent sur le terrain
est vrai qu elle voudrait oublier le
match de la soirée
il ya donc nos neuf autres matches de
cette soirée strasbourg m lens nantes
saint-etienne lille monaco la balle
nîmes bastia valenciennes nice nancy
angibaud gens tout ce vous voilà et tous
les résultats de cette deuxième journée
dans le journal d'hervé claude à 22h30
20 heures de temps pour deux lignes le
sol on a chaud et ensoleillé sur le sud
est de la france avec quelques orages en
soirée sur les montagnes
sur les autres régions temps étant ou
devenant variable avec du soleil et
quelques nuages puis les mondiaux à
l'éloignement le massif central et les
côtes nord est assez beau temps
ensoleillé donc demain sur à peu près
l'ensemble du territoire
comme vous le disiez virer les dernières
informations vous seront présentés par
evry claude demain en scène par jean
claude mongeau même régulièrement 21
secondes
à à dinard vous avez vu cet après-midi
commentée par jean marc est le concours
hippique de dinars au concours hippique
raglan par le ramenant de 20 selon
cheval et de cheval de selle de sport
demain dans un tome de midi et vous
verrez vous entendrez également de
monsieur mouche quand le cheval france
et qui vous donnera un certain nombre de
précisions particulièrement
intéressantes sur l'évaluation des
raisons mystérieuses
et puis à 20 heures demain samedi comme
après demain dimanche
vous retrouverez pour vous présenter
cette édition philippe harrouard bon
soir 20h